i think it's reasonable to think there
will be what i might call sort of
structural change in the economy coming
out of the covert experience and there
will be some parts of the economy which
will just
i'm afraid not be viable going forwards
in the
in the acceptable time frame that they
they planned which best of the economy
well i think
what i say if you look at this uneven
pattern of recovery
and you think what are the sort of
characteristics of those parts that
haven't recovered effectively it is
that the you know the often sectors that
have a very high
i might call sort of social social
consumption element to them
which involves people working in and or
indeed consuming them at very close
quarters
restaurants bars things like that i mean
the uk economy does have a higher share
of those
sectors than quite a number of uh when
you look at other developed countries
interestingly it's not not massively
high but it is actually we are at the
at the top of that uh that list so we're
potentially more exposed to the economic
shock from that perspective i think i
think that helps to explain when people
compare
forecasts across countries and say you
know one of one of the reasons they say
why does the uk look somewhat more
exposed that helps that's one of the
factors that helps to explain it yes
one of the interesting things that's
certainly evolving is the bank's
attitude towards interest rates and
specifically negative interest rates now
hitherto there's been a slight kind of
reluctance to
go there but that's that's perhaps
changing now isn't it
well the message that we're we're giving
today is
if we think about the toolbox of things
that we can pull out and use in
particular circumstances
um two things first obviously
you know the covert shock has has forced
us and required us to look very
carefully at
how many things can we put in the
toolbox because we start in a position
where
with interest rates so near to zero the
toolbox looks you know
thinner in terms of its contents than
than in a normal world
we've had to innovate we've had to you
know look very carefully at the toolbox
over recent months
our conclusion having spent time looking
at negative rates is they should be in
the toolbox
and there's no reason not to have them
in the toolbox it's a matter of
principle
but we're not looking to implement them
at the moment we're not we're not about
to take a decision to do it we're not at
that point
okay that's interesting and but and
another thing that's that's kind of
slightly changed is
now you have the possibility of a no
deal brexit yes
within your forecast you hadn't done
that before had you it is
very complicated at the moment for the
reason that of course
both covid and brexit could potentially
negatively affect trade
if you're thinking about this world
covert is the biggest shock in our in
all our work suggests covers the bigger
shock
moreover of course covert has already
had an effect on trade
quite clearly you can see in the data so
the of course you then get to the
extremely complicated question which i
you know i don't think we're in a
position to give
very much frankly useful guidance on at
the moment which is to say
how much of the you know if you think
about you know the
the less good outcomes uh in brexit than
the central case
but how much of that effect on trade has
actually already been taken over by
what's happened with covered
so what so covert slightly somewhat
dwarfs
i think at the moment it does dwarf it
it dwarfs the impact of a node brexit
even at the moment yes